We Begin tonight with something very
unique to this great country of ours I
think the greatest country God gave man
and that is the United States of America
and it's called freedom of speech in
China Iran many countries countries
around the world you can be killed or
tortured if you express yourself
honestly even democracies in Europe and
Canada they impose fines and and jail
time to those who Voice or dare to voice
opposition or opinions to their
government anything deemed offensive or
unpopular now left us across the globe
they hate Free Speech they always have
they always will they believe that their
own feelings are more important than
your freedom and sadly the same is true
of most Democrats right here in the U.S
but thankfully because of our great
Constitution their Authority is limited
still as The self-anointed Gatekeepers
of information they have worked
tirelessly to coordinate with big Tech
the media mob to hide opposing
viewpoints from you the American people
and for years Twitter was probably the
worst offender of this left-wing
censorship campaign as scores of you
know purple-haired moderators from San
Francisco were cracking down on tweets
that hurt their precious little feelings
and went against their precious
political beliefs now of course we all
remember the very true New York Post
Hunter Biden laptop story that Twitter
censored in the weeks prior to the 2020
presidential election even the
conservative satirical website The
Babylon B was banned from the platform
because of a joke about a Biden official
liberals also they're largely humorless
and they get offended quite easily but
tonight Twitter's war on free expression
is now officially over as billionaire
Elon Musk wrote a very large check and
purchased the tech giant he fired the
moderators he's vowing to turn the
platform into a Town Square where people
on all sides of the political Spectrum
can actually utter and share and express
their opinions and ideas and ideals
freely as Elon Musk put a quote Twitter
has failed in trust and safety for a
very long time and has interfered in
elections now Twitter 2.0 will be far
more effective transparent and
even-handed now today he also urged
Americans to cancel cancel culture
needless to say Democrats they are
seething with rage how dare we cancel
cancel culture take a look
Republicans say that Democrats are
picking on Elon Musk do you what's your
reaction to that Elon Musk is doing just
fine but
but offensive I think that one human
being should not decide how millions of
people communicate with each other and
it doesn't make any difference who that
human being is one human being should
not be able to go into a dark room by
himself and decide oh that person gets
heard from that person doesn't that's
not how it should work
by the way keep in mind it was Elizabeth
Warren had no problem when the site was
unilaterally blocking Republicans
censoring what was likely uh an election
changing story about the Biden family
Syndicate and by the way I'm not exactly
sure that a person that faked her race
for decades and pretended to be a Native
American for financial gain should
really be lecturing anybody about the
Integrity of content moderation but it's
not only Elizabeth Warren even the White
House is pledging to keep a close eye on
Elon Musk and Twitter and monitor their
activities a close eye what does that
mean really is that a threat either way
apparently it is news to the White House
Press Secretary was incapable unable
unwilling to answer basic questions from
our very own peter Ducey take a look
when are you guys going to delete the
White House Twitter account
why would we do that well you're saying
that you're keeping an eye on Twitter
because it might not be a suitable
platform so why use it look I I don't
have anything to share on any policy or
any changes that we will be making we
have multiple platforms as you know that
we utilize to communicate with the
American people when you say that you're
going to be monitoring some of the
speech on there if you see something
that you don't like would you try to
shut Twitter down so look you know when
you when you talk about monitoring you
know it is uh I I hate to break it to
you Peter just like everybody else we
very much monitor the news we pay close
attention to everything that you all are
reporting actually it's clear she's not
monitoring the news that closely
liberals have been loudly complaining
about Elon Musk for weeks many
ironically have been complaining about
him on Twitter now the course of
complaints is so deafening that many
Democrats they're now calling for Apple
and Google to remove Twitter from their
App Store even though Apple CEO Tim Cook
reiterated apparently earlier today that
that's not going to happen with apple
likely afraid that musk will produce an
alternative phone company now the
petulant little tyrants in Western
Europe they're also threatening to block
Twitter if Elon Musk refuses to agree to
their censorship demands so is freedom
really that scary to the left think
about this nobody forces you to go on
Twitter nobody forces you to read
Twitter nobody forces you to have an
account on Twitter nobody forces can't
force you to do anything with Twitter
ever and that brings us back to the
hunter Biden laptop Story the one that
was censored in the weeks before the
2020 presidential election now Twitter's
ex-safety Chief claims that their
suppression of that New York Post
article was a mistake why didn't he say
it at the time of course it wasn't a
mistake was it now Twitter didn't know
if the report was true or fake and they
didn't care they like other big big
social media Giants they wanted Trump to
lose the election they wanted Biden to
win so they censored the story and the
rest is now history mission accomplished
the left doesn't care about the truth
they only care about the narrative and
their power sunlight was always the best
disinfectant and that is precisely why
they're so angry at Elon Musk how dare
he say it's going to be a free and open
Forum anyway the White House can go
ahead and keep their close eye on Elon
Musk but it won't matter because he is
about to expose those democrats for the
left-wing freedom-hating tyrants that
they really are hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else